bonjour Nabilla je parle à l'instant
donc de ces bombardements à l'aide de
highmars en tout cas c'est ce dont parle
la Russie dans tous les cas selon ton
est sûr c'est que les premiers chars
lourds sont arrivés en Ukraine les
challengeurs et les Léopards notamment
c'est ce qu'attendait les autorités
ukrainiennes pour lancer leur
contre-offensif alors la contrefaie pas
encore lancée disons que là l'aide
promise par les occidentaux notamment
sur les chars lourds effectivement et
beaucoup plus moderne que ce que
possèdent les ukrainiens et bien cette
annonce commence vraiment à se
concrétiser sur le terrain c'est à dire
que depuis lundi il y a effectivement
des chars britanniques challengers qui
sont arrivés des chars allemands léopard
E2 sans oublier bien sûr des chars
américains aussi et les chars les
blindés légers français les AMX 10 qui
sont déjà arrivés qui continuent à
arriver ce qui fait que là cette aide
absolument indispensable à l'armée
ukrainienne si elle veut justement
lancer sa contre-offensive ça commence à
devenir concret c'est sur le terrain
c'est en Ukraine et les formations
s'accélèrent pour pouvoir évidemment
manier ses engins avec un petit bémol
encore c'est que apparemment d'après les
informations que nous avons il manque
encore de munitions quand même pour
marcher en quelque sorte avec ses chars
donc tout ça commence à se mettre en
place d'où effectivement l'idée que les
Ukrainiens commencent à réfléchir
sérieusement à la fameuse
contre-offensive dont on parle depuis
l'automne maintenant qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé en fait à l'automne il y a eu ces
contre-offensives
ukrainiennes qui ont permis donc à Kiev
de reprendre un peu des territoires qui
avaient été conquis par les Russes entre
le mois de février et la fin du mois
d'août mais depuis finalement ce qu'on
observe c'est une guerre de position un
front qui est un peu gelé des avancées
timides de part et d'autre côté russe
évidemment on a tous en tête ce qui se
passe à barmouth et à l'heure où on se
parle on a bien
les Russes ne sont toujours pas emparés
de ce qu'il reste de barmouth qui a été
totalement détruite donc les Ukrainiens
se disent qu'avec ces chars occidentaux
alors ils en avaient demandé 300 au
total on en est encore loin mais avec
les chars de l'époque soviétique qu'ils
possèdent déjà et avec ses nouvelles
arrivées il pourrait assez rapidement
avoir entre les spécialistes estiment
entre eux 120 et 150 chars et là on peut
commencer à faire des percées dans le
front alors où et quand évidemment ça
c'est l'autre question
l'idée des Ukrainiens ce serait de
briser le continuum russe en Ukraine et
de de diviser en deux donc soit du côté
de Carson de zapporizia ou carrément
dans le dos basse d'essayer de briser
cette cette ligne russe pour évidemment
affaiblir l'adversaire un adversaire qui
se prépare à cette contre-offensive qui
pourrait avoir lieu dans les semaines à
venir c'est pas une contre-offensive qui
va être déclenché là dans les jours qui
viennent apparemment
ils ont notamment établi des espèces de
d'énormes dents si vous voulez des
dizaines et des dizaines pour empêcher
les chats Ukrainiens de de progresser en
fait ça crée les sacrées les chenilles
en face ça les empêcherait d'avancer
donc voilà on en est là et on se prépare
visiblement très sérieusement côté
ukrainien russe notamment parce que il y
a eu plusieurs prises de parole
notamment le porte-parole du Kremlin qui
parle de guerre hybride donc de durer
dans le temps il y a eu aussi des
livraisons d'armes tactiques à la
Biélorussie alors attention il y a eu
l'annonce de la livraison de ces armes
nucléaires tactiques par le Kremlin on
est dans la une rhétorique assez
classique si vous voulez à chaque fois
qu'il y a une aide occidentale qui
massive qui est annoncée ou qui commence
à se concrétiser sur le terrain Moscou
sort le grand jeu en quelque sorte avec
des déclarations fracassantes c'est vous
l'avez dit Dimitri Dimitri best of qui
dit que la guerre hybride va durer très
longtemps de la Russie et les
Occidentaux c'est l'annonce donc de
livraison d'armes nucléaires tactiques
depuis la Russie vers la Biélorussie
mais selon les Américains il n'y a pas
de mouvement qui a été observé à ce
stade donc ce n'est pas encore fait on
est encore dans le déclaratif mais c'est
là aussi un peu toujours la même carte
que sors Moscou à chaque fois qu'elle se
soit un peu menacées par ces renforts
occidentaux et ben c'est la menace la
menace nucléaire et puis il y a aussi
ces
déclarations et là c'est visiblement
c'est du réel comme quoi il y a des
exercices militaires très importants qui
se déroulent en ce moment en Russie avec
des missiles balistiques
intercontinentaux vous voyez que Moscou
osloton mais c'est bien sûr lié à ce qui
vient d'être annoncé côté occidental et
côté
ukrainien et les Russes eux aussi
préparent une nouvelle offensive au
printemps donc nul doute que dans les
semaines qui viennent le front va
commencer à bouger en fait le problème
pour l'un et l'autre camp c'est d'avoir
ce que les experts militaires appellent
une masse de manœuvre
suffisante c'est-à-dire homme et
matériel pour pouvoir effectuer une
percée dans un conflit qui est pour le
moment sur un front de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres et qui est gelé
depuis l'automne merci beaucoup Bruno